this right over here is an image from an
exercise on Khan Academy and it says
compare using a greater than less than
or equal to and on the Left we have 1/4
times 5,000 and we want to compare that
to 5,000 on Khan Academy you would click
on this drop down and you would pick a
greater than less than or equal to so
what do you think it is
how does 1/4 times 5,000 compare to
5,000 and how do you know your answer is
correct pick one of these choices as
well pause the video and have a go with
that well one way to think about it if
I'm multiplying 5,000 times some value
that value is going to scale 5,000 it's
going to make it smaller or bigger or in
certain cases might not change the size
at all in fact the ones where you don't
change 5,000 which you multiply it by 1
so 1 times 5,000 is equal to 5,000 but
what do you think is going to happen
when you multiply a value that is
between 0 and 1 times 5,000 is that
going to be greater than equal to or
less than 5,000 well one way to imagine
it is on a number line if this is 0 this
is 5,000 this would be halfway between 0
and 5 thousand and if I then make it the
space between 0 and 5 thousand and two
fourths this would be 1/4 of the way
between 0 and 5 thousand so this value
right over here that is 1/4 times 5,000
well how does this value 1/4 times 5,000
compared to this value to 5,000 well
it's clear that 1/4 times 5,000 is less
than is less than 5,000 and in general
if the value is between 0 & 1 that
you're multiplying by something else
it's going to make the thing you're
multiplying smaller if this were 1 it's
not going to change the value and if
this were greater than 1 it would make
it larger so let's see these choices
because we are multiplying 5,000 by a
fraction that is less than 1 yeah that's
exactly what's happening we're
multiplying 5,000 by 1/4 so it's going
to give us a smaller value than 5,000 I
like that choice
let's just read these other ones because
we're multiplying 5,000 by a fraction
that is equal to 1 well no we we create
1/4 is clearly not equal to 1 so we
ruled that one out because we're
multiplying 5,000 by a fraction that is
greater than 1
well 1/4 is clearly not greater than 1
so you rule that out as well let's do
another example so here we're asked is
the product of each expression less than
equal to or greater than 49 so pause
this video and try to figure it out
alright so this first one is 49 times
7/8 so what do you think that's going to
be well 7/8 is less than 1 so if I
multiply 49 times something less than 1
I'm going to get a value that is less
than 49 so I like that choice right over
there 49 times 5 halves well 5 halves is
greater than 1 remember 2 halves would
be equal to 1 so 5 halves is greater
than 1 so if I'm multiplying 49 by a
value that is greater than 1 I'm going
to get a value that is greater than 49
and then last but not least 49 times 3/3
well 3/3 is exactly equal to 1 so 49
times 1 is going to be exactly equal to
49 and we're done